Speaker 1: Of course, remember that if you would
like to chat with me, your nickname in the waiting
lobby on Discord needs to be your name and where
you are calling from your name and where you're
calling from. And like obvious nicknames and jokes
just get skipped, just so people understand that
that's an important consideration, I think,
to keep in mind. Okay. Let's try again with
Nate from Rhode Island to see if the technical
issues have abated. Nate, are you with us now?
Speaker 3: Still early. How's it going, David?
It's going well. So I want to elaborate on a
previous call ahead. So now that we have 51
seats, we can start our own investigations. We
can fast track judges to that podium, especially
excited for good. Now, I don't know if Biden is
for packing the Supreme Court. I'm pretty
sure he said expanding, I should say. But
I'm pretty sure he's not. He's not. We have too
much help there. Yeah, I didn't think so. Yeah.
And also, I'm pretty excited with how fast the
special counsel's been working. He's been working
daily. I mean, indeed. I appreciate. Yeah. Hey, I
didn't know. That's about all they had to say. I
got a driving lesson today, so wish me luck there.
Speaker 1: Wait, so you're teaching or you're
receiving? You're learning to drive.
Speaker 3: Learning to drive to Tripoli.
Speaker 1: Really? How old the guy are you?
Speaker 3: I'm 23, so I'm a little
on the a little older, but not too old.
Speaker 1: And what is it about? You know,
so many people are so eager to get their driver's
licenses as soon as possible. But I know things
have changed from when I was 16. What made
you wait years and years before doing this?
Speaker 3: Very good question. Thank you.
Yeah. So I've really just never needed to
take driving lessons. I've had parents
that have been able to drive me around,
so I've just never really needed it. Yeah, and
the situation has changed a bit. So now I'm like,
okay, so I'll take up driving lessons now.
Speaker 1: And it was never appealing to say like,
Well, even if I mostly don't need to
drive, it'd be great to be able to
rent a car if I needed one. Or is it just
never. It never was appealing until now.
Speaker 3: It's not that I was never appealing.
It's just that I never really needed to, you know.
Speaker 1: You didn't need it.
Interesting. Do you find that you are?
Well, I guess you can't say because you didn't
drive at 16. But I'm wondering, like, if you.
My mom started driving a lot later than a lot of
people and she, like, doesn't drive on the highway
and doesn't like driving fast. She's definitely
like more tentative. Do you find that to some
degree, maybe compared to other drivers, you know?
Speaker 3: Yeah. I mean, I'm so careful that I had
the my last lesson had to be told to speed it up
a little bit. Interesting. Pretty careful. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Interesting. Interesting. All right.
Well, Nate, listen, I hope the lesson goes well
and you have your license before we know it.
Speaker 3: Okay. Thank you very much. Road
test is scheduled for March 1st. Yes, they're.
Speaker 1: Beautiful. All right. There is Nate
from Rhode Island learning to drive. You love to
see it. I love to see people develop
skills. It's a really great thing.